[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 2 juillet m justement ce
vendredi 2 juillet la première séance du
conseil régional d'île de france avait
lieu au siège à saint-ouen à l'ordre du
jour l'installation des nouveaux
conseillers et l'élection du président
et des vice présidents sans surprise
valérie pécresse a été renouvelé à la
tête du conseil régional
nous ferons le point avec jérôme
regnault nouveau conseiller régional de
la majorité et nous écouterons aussi la
réaction de l'opposition
ensuite côté loisirs cette semaine avec
cellier agathe sung ho nous irons
visiter le centre d'entraînement pour
chevaux de maisons laffitte et nous vous
présenterons également le programme de
la cinquième édition de l'événement
jardins ouverts en ile de france
enfin comme chaque semaine vincent
couronne créateur du site internet les
surligneurs décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
aujourd'hui focus sur la proposition
d'exclure la hongrie de l'union
européenne
oh
valérie pécresse et dans cloud
présidente de la région ile de france
comme vous l'avez entendu c'est sans
surprise et une large majorité que
valérie pécresse présidente sortante a
été réélue à la tête du conseil régional
d'île de france
elle a obtenu 125 voix sur 137 suffrages
exprimés une réélection qui a eu lieu ce
vendredi 2 juillet lors de la séance
d'installation des conseillers régionaux
élus dimanche 27 juin dernier pour
rappel la liste de valérie pécresse
était arrivé largement en tête lors des
élections régionales récoltant 125
sièges suivie par celle de l'union de la
gauche avec à sa tête le secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
julien bayou 53 sièges
l'un des conseillers d'opposition de sa
liste a d'ailleurs paul vannier
apparenté à la france n'y avait
d'ailleurs soumis sa candidature à la
présidence obtenant seulement 12 voix
enfin le rassemblement national et la
république en marche avait obtenu
dimanche dernier respectivement 16 et 15
sièges pour la région lors de cette
séance les vice-présidents également et
est élu et parmi les nouveaux
conseillers de la majorité
jérôme regnault agriculteurs et
apiculteurs dans les yvelines
on retrouve nicolas d'enlever au siège
de la région ile-de-france avec lui eh
bien oui elle est au nord je suis avec
jérôme regnault nouveau conseiller
régional élu la semaine dernière dans la
liste de valérie pécresse bonjour
bonjour alors le vote vient d'avoir lieu
valérie pécresse vient d'être élue
présidente de la région ile de france
vos premiers sentiments dans ce dans cet
hémicycle sentiment est évidemment de
satisfaction après un beau parcours de
campagne même dans des conditions très
particulières
puis sentiment que quand on est cohérent
politique qu'on a un bon bilan qu'on le
présente bien et qu'on a un projet
ambitieux malgré le manque de
participation les gens l'ont massivement
reconnu notamment chez nous dans les
yvelines
son département entre guillemets
permanent mais aussi pour nous qualifier
d yves hinse et de vraie fierté c'est un
tout nouveau mandat pour vous c'est le
premier mandat politique
pourquoi vous êtes engagé là aussi de
par le bilan tout le travail qui avait
été fait vis-à-vis de la ruralité il a
vidé des objets agricoles et le côté
ambitieux aussi des propositions à venir
c'est à dire avoir une vision assez
large pertinente mais aussi réconcilier
de l'agriculture en ile-de-france
développer le local avec tout ce que
cela comprend la mise en place du bio
dans nos régions pour nos spécialisée
est également une vision économique et
et progressive des grandes cultures pour
l'ensemble de mes collègues
oui parce qu on le précise à nos
téléspectateurs vous êtes agriculteur
sur le territoire de plaisir pourquoi
vous avez franchi le pas disons vous
étiez engagé déjà dans les associations
professionnelles des agriculteurs
pourquoi avoir voulu s'engager
politiquement
là aussi c'est une question de cohérence
c'est à dire que je me retrouvais à la
fois dense que la mandature précédente
avait su faire pour accompagner les
projets des agriculteurs dans ce cas va
proposer dans ce qu'on va proposer sur
les sur les six ans à venir mais aussi
ce côté ambitieux à chaque fois qu'ils
ont eu besoin de faire appel à la région
elle a été là pour pallier souvent
l'absence de l'état sur de nombreux
sujets donc je me retrouvais
complètement
je n'abandonne pas mon image
professionnelle et
regard de mes collègues et je pourrai
avec fierté les rencontrer demain
vis-à-vis de ce qu'on va proposer en ile
de france
si vous êtes un professionnel donc
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez apporter
des quelle idée vous souhaitez porter du
coup on va essayer d'avoir que des
choses assez intéressantes voire même
novatrice assez rapidement sur la
commission ruralité agriculture
puisqu'ils vont fonctionner ensemble
continuer d'accompagner l'ensemble des
projets que ce soit du financement de
bâti ce soit la facilitation aussi de
mettre en place et projet c'est pas tout
le temps évident vis-à-vis de deux
documents d'urbanisme assez drastiques
dans notre département
le schéma directeur de la région le
sdrif va être révisée sur cette
mandature là aussi des choses très
intéressantes à proposer sur la ruralité
palomo protection parce que il faut pas
mettre l'agriculture sous cloche mais
une vigilance particulière à ne pas
manger du foncier agricole et naturel
tout en maintenant une possibilité de
développer notre activité
la fibre politique vous l'avez aussi
dans le sens puisque votre père joël
regnault il a été maire de plaisir c'est
aussi ça c'est portait aussi un
engagement qui est déjà présent dans
votre famille oui c'était pas c'était
pas l'ambition première mais
d'avoir c'est un petit peu en soit c'est
sûr le goût de la chose publique
le good est habitué à donner au tour
mais mais c'est relatif aussi aux
métiers de l'agriculture c'est à dire
cette possibilité qu'on a de pouvoir
s'entrevoir s'entraider de prendre du
temps de famille et du temps privé aussi
professionnelle pour aider les collègues
pour les représenter ma finalement c'est
ça de la politique un dernier mot
quand vous allez vous organiser parce
que vous gardez votre activité sur
l'exploitation tout en ayant un mandat
politique commence vous êtes organisés
du coup oui on va concilier les deux en
premier chef je reste agriculteurs sur
sur la commune de plaisir ben c'est
comme tous une question d'organisation
de confiance dans des collaborateurs de
qualité
deux employés qui m'accompagne sur
l'exploitation et puis le rythme
politique agriculture ce concile est à
peu près puisque à part aujourd'hui pour
l'installation du conseil régional
globalement l'été politiquement c'est un
peu plus calme quand nous on est
vraiment ans d'activité merci jérôme
regnault on va vous laisser retourner
dans l'hémicycle puisque l'installation
de la nouvelle mandature du conseil
régional se poursuit et justement du
côté de la première opposition du
conseil régional l'union de la gauche
julien bayou réagissez lui aussi au
micro de nicolas landry il est revenu
sur son rôle dans l'opposition écoutez
le moi j'ai deux de préoccupation
d'abord que ce mandat soit pas un mandat
perdu pour le climat pour les
solidarités on voit qu'il ya des
problèmes de canicule valérie pécresse
n'a pas intégré la question climatique
dans son logiciel
nous serons là pour le lui rappeler on a
besoin que le mandat soit pas perdue
pour la génération qui vient ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
l'abstention qui est phénoménal parce
qu'il ya une défiance je crois qu'on
peut comprendre les électeurs les
électrices qui se sont pas déplacés ils
n'ont pas compris les enjeux du scrutin
où il en avait rien à faire ou ils n'y
ont pas cru
beaucoup de bonnes et de mauvaises
raisons le rôle d'un élu régional
c'est justement de tenter de donner tort
de montrer qu'on peut agir dans
l'institution en dehors dans une
démocratie on continue on sera au
service de ses électeurs y compris ce qu
ont pas voté pour nous l'enjeu pour nous
c'est rappeler l'urgence d'agir sur le
climat et les solidarités on l'a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire il ya un
enjeu d'inégalités de lutter contre les
immigrés
qui est de d'anticiper de prévoir la
région ile-de-france à 2030 à 2040 pour
la génération qui vient c'est ça
l'opposition que nous incarnons et plus
de détails seront à retrouver dans le
7-8 journal lundi 5 juillet à 18h en
direct présenté par grégory canal est à
présent retour en 78 secondes sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines avec mélanie poké et juliette
prigent quatrième édition de choose
france lundi 28 janvier le sommet initié
par le président de la république a
réuni près de 150 dirigeants de grands
groupes étrangers et français faciliter
la mise en relation producteurs et
consommateurs la chambre d'agriculture
d'ile-de-france a lancé sa carte
interactive où les professionnels sont
référencés en fonction de leurs produits
et de leur localisation dans moins d'un
mois ce sont les jeux olympiques près de
onze mille athlètes vont se rassembler à
tokyo parmi eux plusieurs yvelinois
qu'il soit triathlète judokas cycliste
ou encore boxeur comme maiva hamadouche
boxeuse licence hier et encore après les
deux tours d'élections le temps de
l'installation ce 1er juillet le conseil
départemental a élu sa présidence s'est
sans surprise pierre bédier qui reste à
la tête de l'instance 12 vice-présidents
aussi été nommé deux ministres dans les
yvelines jean castex s'est rendu à
jambville pour rencontrer plus de 150
jeunes engagés dans un essai news
service national universel
jean baptiste djebbari était lui en
déplacement dans l'entreprise colas à
magny les hameaux
enfin le rapporteur public du conseil
d'état a demandé l'annulation des
élections municipales à trappes
mais sans requérir d'inégibilité pour le
maire génération ali rabais la décision
finale du conseil d'état sur la prise
d'ici deux à trois semaines
après une semaine bien chargée quoi de
mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi c'est lié à 400 go
vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
cette semaine nous allons vous présenter
le seul le centre d'entraînement pour
chevaux de course d'île de france situé
à maisons laffitte
une visite unique vous attend ce samedi
3 juillet puisque l'établissement ouvre
exceptionnellement ses portes au public
piste écuries chevaux vous pourrez
découvrir les lieux et parler avec les
entraîneurs
un reportage de juliette prigent
habituellement fermés au public le
centre d'entraînement pour chevaux de
course de maisons laffitte ouvre samedi
matin ses portes
par petits groupes de 15 personnes vous
pourrez découvrir les 60 hectares et
plusieurs kilomètres de pistes propriété
de france galop le centre d'entraînement
n'est pas ouvert au public puisque comme
vous le voyez avec les chevaux qui
évolue autour de nous on peut pas se
permettre d'avoir des gens qui
déambulent comme ça sur le sur ces lieux
donc l'office du tourisme organise des
visites encadrées par des professionnels
du monde des courses ils peuvent voir le
travail des chevaux le matin et ensuite
ils ont une visite d'écurie pour pouvoir
discuter avec l'entraîneur et voir
comment s'organise le travail et comment
s'organise la vie de l'écurie près de
500 chevaux de course s'entraîner ici
tous les jours ils sont montés par ce
qu'on appelle des lads les cavaliers qui
s'occupe d'entraîner les chevaux pour
les jo qui en fait les chaussons des
athlètes comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
donc il ya un pro qui tend qui ont un
programme de courses et donc ils sortent
effectivement tous les jours samedi et
dimanche compris jour férié il n'y a pas
de repos pour les chevaux de course et
leurs entraîneurs et le personnel qui
gravitent autour
ce centre d'entraînement est le seul en
ile de france pour les chevaux de
courses de galop une opportunité unique
donc de découvrir cet environnement très
important à maisons laffitte
je pense que pour des gens qui habitent
à maisons-laffitte je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui habitent dans la partie ville
et non pas dans le parc qui se rendent
pas forcément compte de ce que
représente le cheval à maisons laffitte
et je pense que c'est une bonne
opportunité de découvrir notre centre
d'entraînement et même pour les communes
avoisinantes
une visite est organisée ce samedi 3
juillet à 9 heures une autre date est
aussi proposé le 31 juillet prochain
ce week end plusieurs animations
nocturnes auront lieu dans les yvelines
astrid bergère bonsoir bonsoir vous
allez nous présenter trois événements
incontournables exactement célia le
premier a lieu au domaine
une halle de saint germain en laye il
s'appelle opéra en plein air on écouta
directrice des opérations
opéra en plein air c'est un festival
d'art lyrique dont le but est de sortir
l'opéra des grands théâtres
ce week-end nous représenterons madame
butterfly dans le domaine nationale de
saint germain en laye dans un domaine
qui est incroyable magnifique un village
de bars et de food truck sera ouvert à
partir de 18h30 et le spectacle
commencera à 20h45 et les enfants ne
sont pas en reste célia l'après midi à
16h un opéra réservé aux plus jeunes
sera joué il s'appelle piccola opéra il
est possible de prendre ses billets en
ligne ou sur place et on part maintenant
à rambouillet à astrid et oui du côté de
la forêt de rambouillet dans le cadre de
la troisième édition du festival de
cinéma branches et signer un film sera
projeté à partir de 22h30 sur un écran
géant
et cette année c'est le cinéma et les
forêts du continent africain qui sont
mis à l'honneur alors c'est une
expérience assez original parce que
c'est en extérieur et au milieu de la
faune et la flore c'est le film drôle
d'oiseau qui sera diffusé et des
animations de auront d'ailleurs lieu
avant la diffusion du film donc de 18h à
22h
et j'ajoute que la projection du film
est gratuite mais qu'il faut s'inscrire
les informations sont à retrouver sur le
site de l'espace rambouillet et qu'est
ce que l'on peut faire du côté de
versailles
alors tout le mois de juillet le potager
du roi accueilli des halles festival
c'est un festival une série de concerts
à 37
ils sont donnés surtout pour encourager
les jeunes talents qui n'ont pas
travaillé depuis longtemps je vais
convaincre certains grands noms consacré
déjà qui se sont aussi proposés sont
éléments comme gérard depardieu carla
bruni fanny ardant de se mêler à cette
musique classique pour que leur concert
soutiennent les cachets de ces ces
jeunes musiciens qui viennent de france
et d'europe
et ce samedi 3 juillet à 19 heures il y
aura un duo piano-violon 2 2
this taurus et à 21h carla bruni se
produira sur scène accompagné d'un
sextuor à cordes
la réservation est obligatoire sur le
site de l'idéal festival du potager du
roi merci beaucoup astrid pour toutes
ces idées fêter la nature et la culture
jardin ouvert revient pour une nouvelle
édition estivale du 3 juillet au 29 août
la région ile de france organisatrice de
l'événement proposera des centaines
d'animations et d'ateliers culturels et
éducatifs dans plus de 200 espaces verts
eric gross bonsoir mechouar vous êtes le
directeur de la culture de la région
ile-de-france en jardins ouverts a pour
objectif de faire découvrir le
patrimoine naturel de façon insolite ans
c'est bien ça absolument bonjour écoutez
vous parlez de jardins ouverts cette
cinquième édition
je me suis installé sur une des
terrasses végétalisées de du siège de la
région ile-de-france à saint-ouen c'est
très beau et il ya du soleil et j'espère
qu'il y en aura ce week end
effectivement pour l'ouverture de jardin
ouvert qu'est ce que ces jardins ouverts
du 3 juillet au 28 août
c'est une opération destinée à offrir
aux franciliens une respiration en les
invitant à découvrir ou à visiter les
jardins de leur territoire plus de 200
jardins qui seront ouverts pendant toute
cette période 3 juillet 28 août presque
deux mois 200 jardins et 350 animations
alors vous savez la région ile de france
12 millions d'habitants douze mille
kilomètres carrés
c'est une région très dense très
urbanisées c'est aussi une région très
vert 78 % de la surface de l'île de
france
ce sont des espaces naturels les espaces
agricoles ou forestiers et aussi des
jardins des parcs et c'est ça que
l'opération jardins ouverts voudrais
inviter les franciliens à découvrir et
c'est aussi de sa queue
nous voulons les invités à ce en
quelques sortes a profité à ceux à se
délecter est alors quels sont les lieux
yvelinois du coup que l'on peut
retrouver
il y en a beaucoup il y en a beaucoup
il ya évidemment le potager du roi à
versailles la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet le parc du château de
monte-cristo le parc du domaine de saint
germain en laye le parc du domaine royal
de de marly les granges de port royal
mais également le jardin de la maison
jeanne et léon blum à jouy en josas ou
le magnifique désert de rett à
chambourcy
je ne peux pas les citer tous mes livres
il fait effectivement partie des
départements
je dirais à ces privilégiés sur le plan
d'eau des espaces verts et des jardins
alors il y aura deux temps forts qui
marqueront l'événement
donc le week-end de clôture et le
week-end bien sûr de lancement donc est
ce que l'on pourra découvrir le 3 et 4
juillet prochains dans les sites où les
tous les lieux que je viens de citer
effectivement avec de la musique de la
musique classique du barreau de la
sculpture moi je vous invite vraiment à
investir tous et tous ces espaces et
tous ces jardins ce que vous êtes sûr
d'y trouver plus pendant ces deux
week-ends de fermeture peut-être que
dans la période qui va qui va les
séparer
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de théâtre de
poésie de lectures poétiques de musique
encore une fois classiques ou modernes
et en particulier dans les lieux que
j'ai citées dans les yvelines
parce que c'est un peu la terre de cette
musique beaucoup de baroque
alors il y aura un grand concours de
photos ans qui est également organisée
autour de la thématique de l'arbre
comment on peut y participer alors c'est
très simple c'est effectivement un
concours autour de la thématique de
l'arbre donc à l'occasion de vos visites
dans ses jardins dans ces espaces
vous êtes chaque francilien chaque
visiteur sera invité à photographier ce
qui lui semblera relever de la
thématique de l'arbre nacht son
entourage
sa floraison sa fugue et on est tous à
du tu jusqu'au 14 juillet et il suffit
de se rendre sur avoir tous les
renseignements sur la plateforme
enfin sur le site de la région
ile-de-france point fr dans le tir et
jardins ouverts
c'est organisé avec la plateforme oui
c'est très simple de du sage très bien
rêver c'est noté merci beaucoup et
rigoureuse d'avoir été notre invité je
vous en prie et pour finir cette page
loisirs je vous propose des idées de
sorties pour ce week end avec la nuit
européenne des musées qui revient pour
une 17e édition
à cette occasion le château de
versailles propose une découverte d'un
endroit exceptionnellement ouvert au
public
ces écuries de l'ue rares sont à visiter
la galerie des sculptures et des
moulages et la galerie des carrosses
rendez vous donc samedi 3 juillet de 19h
à minuit
venez faire une bonne action ce week end
lors de la traditionnelle foire aux
livres et jouets aux clayes-sous-bois
organisée par l'association pour la
luttre la lutte contre les maladies
génétiques
tous les bénéfices seront directement
reversés à l'afm téléthon en décembre à
l'occasion de la 35e édition du téléthon
cette foire est organisée en plein air à
l'école marcel pagnol de 10h à 18h
samedi 3 juillet et de 10 heures à 13
heures dimanche 4 juillet et l'émission
continue avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour refermer 7,8 week-end comme chaque
semaine votre rendez-vous en partenariat
avec les surligneurs on écoute vincent
couronne docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des surligneurs peut-on expulsé la
hongrie de l'union européenne la
question est de plus en plus pressante à
mesure que le premier ministre hongrois
s'éloigne 8 même de ce qui fait des
valeurs de l'union tolérance et non
discrimination
or avec sa loi anti propagande des lgbt
viktor orban est sérieusement en train
de fâcher toute l'europe
mais peut-on pour autant mettre à la
porte cet état d'europe centrale qui
n'ont fait qu'à sa tête la philosophie
de la construction européenne c'est une
construction justement et non une
déconstruction depuis 1957 et le traité
de rome qui font de la communauté
économique européenne
les gouvernements des états membres ont
tenu à mentionner qu'ils sont déterminés
à établir les fondements d'une union
sans cesse plus étroite entre les
peuples européens
c'est présent dans le préambule des
traités c'est pour cela qu'on parle
d'intégration européenne cédant quelque
sorte un processus à sens unique sauf à
faire comme les britanniques qui se
refusant à participer à ce processus
d'intégration ont décidé d'eux mêmes de
quitter le club
il ya donc un moyen de sortir et cela
depuis le traité de lisbonne en 2007
mais est ce n'est pas qu'une audience de
style
cette sortie se fait à l'initiative de
l'état et donc pas de l'union européenne
il faudrait user de tout son poids
diplomatique pour forcer un et a
déclenché la procédure de sa propre
sortie en le menaçant en l'humiliant le
placard dix ans jusqu'à ce que de guerre
lasse il s'en aille ou bien jusqu'à ce
qu'une nouvelle majorité arrive au
pouvoir et se réconcilier avec ses
voisins donc une fois qu'on est entrés
dans l'union on ne peut plus vous mettre
à la porte mais on peut tout à fait vous
montrer où elle se trouve
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine et d'ici là à passer
une bonne soirée un très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ans
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]